To be able to solve this, it'll be helpful to go back and take a good look at the algorithm.
There's really two little blocks of things that are going on.
For each node, we check all of its neighbors and once you add that up over all possible nodes
whether all the neighbors of all the nodes, that's (M), so it's constant work for each of those edges.
But for each of the node, we also have to do this shortest distance-so-far operation
and also to remove the shortest distance-so-far operation and so that is, for each node,
It has to do this which using the implementation that we're looking at is another end.
However, the number of edges is always going to be between 0 and n² roughly.
So this quantity really is somewhere between n² and 2(n²). All that is Θ(n²).
So going back to the set of choices, Θ(n²) is what we're looking for.
Now that's a larger running time than most of the things we've look at so far
and in fact, we can do better and I'm hoping that you've already made the realization that
if you got a bunch of values and the two things you want to do with them is, well, more than two things,
you want to be able to find the smallest, you want to be able to delete the smallest,
and you want to be able to take a value that's already in there
and possibly change it to some other value.
That seems like the sort of things that a heap would be really good at.
All right, so let's actually figure out how we can use a heap
in this particular algorithm to get a better running time.